distribution d'eau minérale pour tous
les élèves pendant la récréation
depuis deux jours la consommation de
l'eau du robinet est interdite par
l'établissement le temps de connaître
les causes exactes des malaises et
vomissements qui touche 168 élèves
encore absent aujourd'hui soit la moitié
de l'établissement ont fait des
distributions d'eau parce que il ya
quinze jours suite à des travaux qui ont
lieu dans la ville de marcigny on avait
trouvé de l'eau trouble
donc on nous avait rassurés en quelques
heures tout était réglé et étant donné
que de nombreux élèves étaient malades
la première idée qu'on a eue c'était que
l'eau pouvait peut-être en est la cause
cette eau du robinet n'est plus trouble
aujourd'hui
mais la principale a souhaité prendre
toutes les précautions au réfectoire
l'eau de la fontaine est également parti
en analyse tout comme les échantillons
de repas même si la cantine continue de
fonctionner le service du département
quand ils ont été alertés ont pris
contact donc avec les services de la
ddpp
donc direction départementale de la
protection des personnes pour se
déplacer donc sur place et pour
effectuer des premiers des premières
vérifications quant à la traçabilité de
la préparation des repas
il s'avère que donc tout a visiblement
été respectée pour apaiser la situation
et assurer de son soutien
l'inspecteur d'académie s'est déplacé
cet après midi je le dis aussi
m'enquérir de la santé des enfants qui
sont actuellement les enfants et des
adultes qui sont actuellement malades la
connaissons cirès une enfants
hospitalisés qui est sous sous
surveillance des résultats des analyses
de l'eau et des échantillons de repas
sont attendus en début de semaine
prochaine